[Musik]
jeder dritte Deutsch hat keine Rücklagen
muss Angst vor hohen Energiekosten haben
gleichzeitig waren immer Melan trete vor
allem möglichen Blackout wie bitter wird
dieser Winter und hilft es den Frauen im
Iran wenn sich europäische Frauen die
Haare abschneiden viel zu besprechen
heute Abend mit diesen Gästen Publizist
und Buchautor Henrik broder er sagt die
Frauen im Iran sind die Waren Feministen
Ralf Freund er ist Vertreter der
Republic ins oversees Germany und
fordert wir müssen Opfer für Frieden und
Freiheit bringen Anti mobbing-coach
Carsten Stahl ist heute hier mit einer
Warnung an die Politik das Volk verarmt
ich nehme an er wird es wie gewohnt sehr
motiviert vorstellen Schriftsteller ist
Stanislav Straßburger fordert Frieden
für die Ukraine schön dass Sie alle hier
sind mein Name ist Lena schick und ich
freue mich heute Abend ihre Gastgeberin
zu sein mich beschäftigt die Panikmache
der Politik die Zeitung Welt berichtete
heute wappnen sich Städte und Gemeinden
schon für den Ernstfall steinfurz
Landrat Martin Sommer waren eindringlich
vor Stromausfällen die länger als 72
Stunden gehen
aus Viersen geht sogar noch weiter und
dreht seinen Bürgern wie übrigens auch
viele andere Kreise sich für eine
mögliche gasmangelage oder Stromausfälle
vorzubereiten die Rheinische Post
liefert direkt mal die Tipps mit man
sollte Bargeld im Haus haben Essen 14
Tage und zwei Liter Flüssigkeit pro
Person pro Tag den Bürger wird also auch
noch erklärt wie man eigentlich am
besten ein Vorrat aufbaut als könnte er
das nicht ich frage mich wie kommt man
auf solche infantinen Vorschläge und
warum verbreitet die Politik derartige
Blackout Panik fakt ist gemessen an den
Fischständen unserer Gasspeicher können
wir vorerst halbwegs entspannt in den
Winter gehen am Dienstag teilte die
Bundesnetzagentur erst mit dass die
aktuellen Füllstände bei 92% liegen
damit sind wir im soll die Gasversorgung
ist also in Deutschland aktuell stabil
mich befremdet dieses in der
Gesellschaft herrschen scheidet das
Licht aus bleibt zu Hause spart Gas legt
euch Vorräte an morgen geht die Welt
unter erst war Corona Schuld jetzt die
Energiekrise und ich möchte von Herr
Broder wissen wann Kosmetik endlich auf
den Menschen solche Angst zu machen Herr
Bruder ich will gar nicht ausschließen
dass die Politik diesmal richtig liegt
das wird tatsächlich die Katastrophe von
der gewarnt wird vielleicht bald erleben
werden keine Panikmache sondern das ist
schon Panikmache das tolle ist ja beides
auf einmal es ist einmal die Warnung von
einem Notstand der eintreten könnte wo
ich glaube auch eintreten wird und zum
anderen ist das natürlich Panikmache es
ist die Fortsetzung der corona-politik
möglichst viele Leute einen
Wohlverhalten zu nötigen und dazu zu
bringen sich Ratschläge anzuhören die
teilweise albern aber teilweise auch
nicht albern sind eine wichtige Sache
wurde da vergessen wenn sie keinen Strom
haben können Sie auch wieder Toilette
nicht benutzen und das ist
wahrscheinlich der größerer Gau und es
wird wahrscheinlich ein Stromausfall
geben dass die Gasspeicher gefüllt sind
das sagt gar nichts das können die
Leitungen unterbrochen werden und wenn
es keinen Strom gibt können Sie kein
Wasser in den dritten stockpumpen und
Sie können auch nicht tanken an der
Tankstelle also die Wahrscheinlichkeit
im Blackout den ich mir nicht wünsche
ist sehr groß andererseits sehe ich
schon ein gewisses zu teuer Bedürfnis
daran nicht dass es es gab mal so ein
berühmten Schnee Winter wo Leute bei
Kiel im Zug eingeschneit worden die
haben davon noch 10 Jahre geschwärmt
nicht man kann sich näher man kommt der
kuscheln und dann hat man eine
Katastrophe überlebt es gibt ein großes
Bedürfnis in Deutschland nach
Katastrophen und nach überleben ich
glaube wir sind jetzt da wo 45 aufgehört
hat
merken Sie das auch wenn Bürgern
ihn richtig Bock auf Katastrophe und
überall ich spür
e das nicht schwer Bruder das sagt
sondern ich spüre das schon knallhart
denn viele Menschen da draußen sehen
mich als jemand der für sie die Stimme
erhebt und ich höre jeden Tag und lese
jeden Tag die Angst der Menschen wie
verzweifelt sie sind dass sie nicht
wissen wie sie ihre Energiekosten
bezahlen kann dass sie Angst davor haben
ein
Blackout könnte eintreten was dann alle
damit folgt ich komme aus Berlin Neuköln
ich bin auf der Straße wo sie geworden
ich kann mich mit Gewalt aus ich weiß
wie schnell sie entsteht wenn
Plünderungen entstehen oder Gewalt
entstehen oder dann noch andere schlimme
Dinge also ich sehe das nicht so rosig
ja wie vielleicht jetzt Sie vielleicht
das jetzt gerade erklären ich finde es
auch schön ich weiß ich weiß ich
persönlich höre diese Angst und dieser
Verzweiflung und dann sehe ich eine
Politik die ein Haufen Scheiße erzählt
die Almosen verteilt wir brauchen einen
gasdeckel der für alle wirklich wirkt
und wenn diese Politik weiterhin
machen Sie sie feiern sich im
Oktoberfest keine Masken offensichtlich
das ist das eine mit 13 Euro Krügen
feiern sie sich das ist der Platz gegen
die maskenpflicht eigentlich müssten sie
doch die Politiker gut finden die jetzt
auch mal sagen es reicht nach
zweieinhalb Jahren oder also
grundsätzlich bin ich gegen die
Maßnahmen weil ich einfach die Meinung
bin wir haben jetzt genug wir müssen
damit leben und das sagte Herr Buschmann
aber wir haben ein paar Fanatiker haben
besessen Leute erlauterbach ist der
größte davon wenn schon wundert jetzt
hat er vier Tage nicht getötet
wahrscheinlich nichts daran dass er mit
seinem Spruch mit wir sind im Krieg mit
Putin wahrscheinlich einfach etwas
losgelöst hat dass die Leute jetzt
wirklich sagen mehr scheiße geht nicht
und dabei andere denken aber es ist ja
eine Geschichte wenn man etwas fordert
und die sagen wir sollen was nun an
manchen besonders unsere Kinder sollen
jetzt bald wieder Masken kann dann
müssen sie das auch vormachen wenn sie
nicht vormachen finde ich sehr
eigentlich gut weil dann sollen sie
endlich wieder scheiße aus also wie
findest Heuchelei es ist eine verlogene
doppelmoralische und noch mal wenn wir
da wenn die so ein Maß haben weil 13 €,
der eine Kuh kostet riesen Fleischplatte
vor sich 13 80 mit Trinkgeld 15 Euro
aber wir haben daraus Menschen die nicht
wissen wie sie ihre Rechnung bezahlen
sollen die die Inflationsrate sehen die
nicht mehr haltbar ist dann findet er
den hohen auf die Verarmung kommen wir
auch später heute in der Sendung zurück
Herr Straßburger wie empfinden Sie es
denn die aktuelle ich ich empfinde schon
als Blackout Panik muss ich sagen ich
denke mir schon die Politik kann man
dann runterfahren ja also mich erinnern
das tatsächlich aus der Kontext schon
gefallen hier mit corvit also ich sehe
da auch eine gewisse Kontinuität in der
Bevormundung des Bürgers also das
praktisch die Politik kommt und sagt ja
wie sollen wir uns verhalten wie sollen
wir Hände waschen wir sollen wir zu
Hause heizen wie lange sollen wir
duschen und so weiter und das ist für
mich ein bisschen befremdlich also ich
muss sagen ich komme ja auch
ursprünglich aus Warschau ich habe ja
auch schon ein noch ein paar Jahre
praktisch der das damaligen Systems in
der Volksrepublik wollen von erlebt und
ein paar Erinnerungen kommen dabei hoch
eben eine
eine Politik die meint Bildung betreiben
zu müssen in einem sehr plakative Art
und Weise und
es ist nicht an nicht die Frage warum
die Politik das macht dann müsste man
vielleicht die Politik fragen warum sie
das eigentlich machen
aber ich fühle ein Unbehagen ich glaube
ich bin verantwortlich genug meine
Eltern haben mich erzogen und paar
andere Leute um mich herum und jetzt bin
ich auch erwachsen genug um zu sagen
okay das und das kann ich in meinem
Leben machen heute noch eine Wohnung in
Warschau wenn ich das hier erwähnen darf
das heißt sie haben eigentlich zwei aber
ja aber das heißt wenn sie jetzt
wirklich in der Not würden sie dann in
Berlin oder Warschau wo haben sie mehr
vertrauen
das ist die Zeit noch hin und her zu
schwere Frage es wäre Frage
[Musik]
ob das
zusammenhängt praktisch mit der mit der
Klima also mit mit der mit den
Heizkosten oder damit mit der Situation
der Wohnsituation da bin ich mir
unsicher
insofern als Kate Polen hat jetzt ein
bisschen auch eine andere Politik die es
im Hinblick auf die Ressourcen für das
es gibt hier diese Ball bleiben zwischen
Norwegen und Polen das wissen sie alle
hier und das ist noch mal ein Versuch
das ein bisschen anders abzusichern ich
bin kein Fachmann um das hier zu
vergleichen und zu sagen wo bin ich dann
tatsächlich sicherer emotionale Frage wo
sie weniger Panik empfunden
also ich empfinde keine Panik weil ich
mich bislang irgendwie nicht in Panik
versetzen lasse aber ich habe das
durchgemacht am Anfang des Kowitz also
da hatte ich tatsächlich irgendwie ich
habe es nicht verstanden was los ist ich
habe mich gefragt ja wie kann das jetzt
auf einmal sein in dem vereinten Europa
ich kann mein Vater der in Warschau
wohnt mein er wohnt in der Wohnung
auf einmal vielleicht gar nicht besuchen
weil mir eine bundesreg gesagt ja ich
darf jetzt nicht die Grenze überfahren
oder die polnische Regierung wird mir
sagen da darf nicht ich hier bleiben ich
habe zwei Staatsangehörigkeiten und wie
mein Vater da und ich hier und wie soll
das funktionieren oder Fragen
vereinigte Europa
lässt mich nicht in eine Nachbarstadt
fahren weil was ich meine wird da
schlimmer sein mit kurvit als hier oder
das habe ich nicht verstanden und das
die Zeiten nie wieder erleben Herr
Freund die Frage hier an Sie wenn Sie
jetzt auf die würden sie es auch als
Bevormundung beschreiben wie ich es ja
getan habe also diese Stimmung Licht aus
weniger heizen ist es ja auch und Herr
Stahl hat ja ein paar schöne Beispiele
gebracht hier innenpolitisch mit dem
Bier gibt ein paar andere Sachen wir
machen jetzt eine Fußball-WM mit
gekühlten Stadien im Winter in Katar die
tollsten Sachen in der frage ich mich so
ein bisschen das können wir uns leisten
da wir zu Hause sollen dann wir haben
immer sagt dann den Gürtel enger
schnallen und sollen dann kalt duschen
das kannst ja nicht gewesen sein die
Politik nein also die Politik muss dafür
sorgen dass auch breite bevöl
Geschichten und nicht nur einige Ebenen
Genuss kommt dass es eben abgefedert
wird und wir haben eben zur Zeit ein
Europa Krieg und wir müssen eben mit den
Konsequenzen leben und schon sehen die
Politik kann dafür nicht sorgen das ist
schon wenn sie von falschen Prämissen
ausgehen kommen Sie automatisch zu
falschen Ergebnissen ja die Politiker
ist als machtlos und willenlos erwiesen
und nein es war vieles absehbar es war
eine Politik des Durchhaltens des
durchwurschstands wir hatten 16 Jahre
Stillstand und es ist auch unfair Frau
Merkel dafür verantwortlich zu machen
hier gilt wieder das Führerprinzip
wissen sie Merkel ist an allem schuld
oder man Merkel ist nur gewusst hätte
nein das ganze Land war eine Art tief
tiefkühlt vollkommen Recht nur jetzt zur
Zeit damit gerechnet dass jetzt passiert
und die Aufgabe
warum sagen Sie das die Politik nicht
dafür Verantwortung tragen kann dass wir
jetzt eine Krise haben ich meine wenn
die Bundesrepublik aber in Europa
Eintritt in einem Krieg also wir
befinden uns jetzt nicht direkt in einem
Krieg aber wir haben uns verbündet wir
eine Kriegspartei aber wir sollten
verbündet mit einer Kriegspartei und ich
meine wenn man eine solche Entscheidung
trifft und dann und sozusagen in
Anführungsstrichen unter dieser
Voraussetzung man zieht in den Krieg mit
einem Gegner sonst 40% unseres Gas
liefert dann gibt's doch irgendwie auch
eine Entscheidungsfindung die uns sagt
wie soll ich ein Krieg machen gegenüber
einen von denen ich völlig ener gut man
kann natürlich auch vorsorglich
kapitulieren weil man von jemand
abhängig ist das machen zum Beispiel
geschlagene Ehefrauen die sich in ihr
Schicksal fügen aber das meinte ich gar
nicht ja meinte nur dass die Situation
der Energieknappheit was voraussehbar
und die Leute diese Situation übersehen
oder sogar herbeigeführt haben mit ihren
Fantasien von Elektroautos und von
flotierenden elektrospeichern die sind
für die Situation verantwortlich wälzen
das aber dann nach uns ab ich weigere
mich kürzer zu duschen ich weigere mich
ein Waschlappen zu benutzen ich habe wie
sie die ersten 11 Jahre meines Lebens in
Polen verbracht und ich habe eine
Waschlappen Allergie seitdem ja und die
erzählen uns jetzt dass wir dafür
verantwortlich sind was die versaut
haben oder an der Stelle mache ich nicht
mit wir machen mal hier ein einen Cut
und gehen mal zu Ihnen Herr Stahl und
Fragen ja mal bei Ihnen nach ihre
Teesorte ab wie ist die aktuelle
Situation in Deutschland wo fahren sie
Angst
wenn das so weitergeht und die Politik
sich weiter so verhält mit ihren grünen
links gesteuerten Ideologie und damit
unser ganzes landgeiselt wir reden hier
von nicht mal 20%, die die gewählt haben
und die schreiben uns vor maßen sich an
sind übergriffig wie wir hier und zu
verhalten haben Waschlappen dann kann
ich nur sagen ich merke schon dass die
Menschen einfach nicht mehr können die
Schnauze voll haben und ist brodelt und
wenn die Damen und Herren im Bundestag
mal aus ihren Palästen rauskommen würden
und sich mal zwischen die Bürger stellen
würden dann würden sie es auch merken
wie sie haben das Angst mit Eiern
beschmissen zu werden und bei vielen von
denen leider das haben sie auch alles
dafür getan ich kann nur sagen wenn das
so weitergeht
befürchte ich dass wir Übergriffe haben
werden und jetzt passen Sie auf das
entscheiden ist ja eins Herz ist wenn
der erste Polizist zu Tode kommt oder
der erste Bürger zu Tode kommt dann gibt
es Massen und ruhen und was passiert
dann setzen wir denn die Bundeswehr
einen inneren was passiert dann und dann
ist es wie so ein wie so ein Dominostein
der wird immer weitergeht und dann
gibt's ja auch welche die Nummer darauf
warten dass die ersten Steine fliegen
und dann das Mitmachen und davor habe
ich Angst dass das passiert wenn das
immer weiter außer Kontrolle geredet und
die Politik soll entweder endlich
handeln und zwar so dass es für alle
nutzt oder verdammt noch mal geschlossen
zurücktreten denn das was sie jetzt
bringen ist beschämend ist zum größten
Teil asozial und vor allen Dingen wenn
sie etwas fordern sollen sie es
vormachen das tun sie nicht und deswegen
sind sie nämlich ultragbar bei dem was
sie da abziehen also einmal
zusammengefasst sie vor der Neuwahlen
ganz ehrlich da vielleicht wissen sie
das ja nicht wir haben letzte darüber
geredet ich bin mit Marcel Luther
angetreten in Berlin wir sind angetreten
und man hat diese Wahlen beschissen hat
man da man hat gestaltet es unterirdisch
man habt ihr Demokratie mit Füßen
getreten man hat man hat einen Marathon
stattfinden lassen zu einer Zeit wenn
unsere Wahl nicht mehr mehr sicher sind
und wir jetzt darüber diskutieren müssen
ob oder nicht wiederholen natürlich
müssen die wiederholt werden und wenn
die wiederholt werden müssen wir auch im
Bundestag wieder runter und dann wollen
wir doch mal sehen ob sie dann immer
noch so gewählt wie jetzt ein paar
verstrahlte Schafe sind immer dabei das
machen sie wenn das Wahlergebnis das
gleiche sein wird wir gehen davon
ausgehen
ich komme mit okay
Herr Freund sie haben gerade gesagt als
Herr Stahlos gelegt hat auch über die
Unruhen zu reden auf den Straßen haben
sie gesagt ganz sicher wird es passieren
ist damit die Politik trägt
Verantwortung dass wir muss darauf
reagieren auf internationale Konflikte
und dieses internationale Konflikt führt
zu hören Energiepreisen zu anderen
Verwerfung der Lieferketten und so
weiter und so fort und diese
Disproportion ich bin selbst Volkswirt
und diese Disproportion muss die Politik
so gut sie eben kann eben ausgleichen
und wenn sie das nicht tut produzieren
eben solche Dinge wenn es eben
unterbleibt dann haben wir eben mit
diesen sozialen Unruhen wie wir sie aus
Frankreich kennen wie wir sie aus
einigen teilweise aus Großbritannien
kennen haben wir dann mit umzugehen und
zu leben dass sie selber Volkswirt sind
ich habe damals in meinem bwl-kursen
gelernt die Politik stellt die
Rahmenbedingungen und der Rest ist
eigentlich in der Wirtschaft das gilt
nur für die Marktseite dann haben Sie
noch die Seite des Staates der
logischerweise Dinge entgegen muss der
Staat schon viel zu sehr aus den
Rahmenbedingungen raus ist und
eigentlich wie ein Vater und wie eine
Mutter über den Bürgern wacht dann
müssen wir ein bisschen
diesen Vorgaben die wir hier eben alle
ein bisschen kritisiert haben muss sie
weniger duschen muss da ein bisschen
mehr frieren muss da weniger Auto fahren
und da mehr zu Fuß gehen dass sie eine
Sache die andere Sache ist der
sogenannte umverteilungsprozess in der
Stadt macht der Staat sorgt eben für die
Verteilung der Güter und werden immer
meine unverteilung in Deutschland das
ganz normal ist und von oben nach unten
das ist völlig okay wir müssen nur sehen
dass es nicht nur Kosten auch aber das
ist eben nicht nur die Menge ist
entscheidend sondern wir Stahl richtig
sagt es muss auch zielgerichtet sein so
gießkannten Prinzip Methoden haben wir
viele erlebt und es riesen
Ressourcenverschwendung wir werden sich
vorstellen diese 300 Euro vorher nur 160
ankommt Frechheit und jetzt überlegen
wir doch mal die bekommen ja sogar die
600 Leute im Bundestag was ist da
wirklich besser dann 1000 € an die zu
verteilen diese wirklich brauchen und
selbst 1000 € sind ein Witz wenn die
jetzt das fünf oder sechs oder
siebenfache an nur wer sind für sie die
Menschen die es wirklich brauchen um bis
jetzt mal zu zu ganz ganz speziell zu
sagen die Menschen die es wirklich
brauchen das sind die die wahrscheinlich
schon auch vorher die sind wir haben 14
Millionen Menschen die in Armut leben
und das wird immer mehr
werdenfänger wer sind für die die sie
die es wirklich brauchen die Menschen
die sozial schwächer gestellt sind also
da und da müssen wir wirklich gucken wer
die auch sind das muss gerecht verteilt
werden wie wir das schon gesagt haben
aber wir haben auch Menschen die aber da
gibt's ja verschiedene Gruppen es gibt
Aufstocker es gibt Hartz IV Empfänger es
gibt ja ganz verschiedene Gruppen 500
Sozialmaßnahmen und keine überschaut ist
genau also ich frage mich halt sie haben
eben selber es gießkanntprinzip
angesprochen und ich würde es vielleicht
andersrum fahren
wird nicht benötigt wird fangen wir doch
mal erst an dann wegzunehmen die genug
haben besonders im Bundestag vielleicht
sogar
interessiert mich schon sehr weil zum
Beispiel
die man soll mehr denen geben die
weniger haben hat ja das
Bürger geführt das müssten Sie ja dann
eigentlich eine gute Maßnahme finden
grundsätzlich ist es schon ein gutes
Geld aber gute Maßnahme die Frage ist
wie viel von den Bürgern sind denn
vielleicht auch wieder besser gestellt
und brauchen es weniger und welche
brauchen es mehr man sollte schon
differenzieren und gucken darauf gucken
dafür ist ja wir haben gerade 520.000
freie Jobs in diesem Land muss man nicht
eher schauen wie man die Menschen in
Arbeit bekommt anstatt mehr zu verteilen
das wäre schon gut dann muss die Arbeit
aber auch lukrativ sein wir haben das ja
mittlerweile schon so dass viele
Menschen ich weiß nicht wie weit wir das
jetzt mitgeschickt das schon mit viele
Menschen sagen sich warum soll ich denn
noch arbeiten gehen wenn wenn
verwerflich aber das liegt auch an der
Politik wenn wir jetzt zusammen ist doch
ganz einfach das Sozialstaat hat versagt
der Sozialstaat versagt jeden Tag und so
mit Umverteilung kriegen sie nicht
hinein das ist eine uraltes
Missverständnis dass sie
Einkommensunterschiede und Wohlstands
Unterschiede bei Umverteilung hinkriegen
wenn man Rockefeller enteignen würde
hätte jeder Amerikaner vielleicht 50
Cent für mich reichen
deswegen das umverteilungskonzept eine
Banalität und wissen Sie dass das zum
Prinzip dieser Regierung geworden ist
ist nur ein weiteres Versagen übrigens
glaube ich nicht dass es zu Unruhen
kommen wird es wird zu unrund kommen
aber es wird kein Straßenkampf geben die
Leute sind müde müssen Sie
wahrscheinlich viel besser als ich die
sind einfach damit absorbiert und
beschäftigt ihren täglichen Kram zu
regeln sie haben nicht mehr die Kraft
auf die Straße aber sie haben auch nicht
mehr den sie haben auch nicht mehr das
Geld teilweise zu überlegen was sie zu
bezahlen kann und schauen Sie mal wenn
sich überlegen Mieter oder nicht ist
doch immer dieses schöne solange der
Deutsche immer noch sein Fußball in sein
Bier hat ja ja mittlerweile kann er sich
noch nicht mal den Fernseher leisten und
der Bier wird immer teurer und was ich
daran immer so also extrem verwerflich
finde der dass wir reden immer davon was
der Staat alles tut wisst ihr liebe
Staatsdiener
ihr vergisst immer eins bei jeder
Preiserhöhung alles was teurer wird haut
ihr eure Steuer auf warum passt sich
eure Steuer eigentlich nicht den
preisverhältnissen an ich meine überall
19% hier darf der Energiesteuer das
jetzt wenn das muss doch angepasst
werden Öffentlichkeit erreichen die
begeistert ist weil sie einen 9 € Ticket
bekommt und dann transportiert wird
unter Umständen die bei jedem
Viehtransport verboten werden würden
nein das Sozialstaat hat versagt weil er
viel zu viel versuchter zu leisten über
50% der stadtbudgets gehen auf soziale
Zwecke Forschung Wissenschaft
Hochschulen Bildung haben viel einen
viel geringeren Anteil an den
Staatsausgaben als die Bekämpfung der
Armut und es gibt eine seltsame
Korrelation vielleicht können Sie mir
das erklären als Volkswirt ihr mehr
Sozialhilfe im Sommer Armut er kann doch
was nicht stimmen hier würde ich auch
gerne einmal erfreut Fragen ist ist der
Staat einfach ein wahnsinnig schlechter
Unternehmer er muss gar kein Unternehmer
genug Steuern ein wir sind auf Platz
zwei bei dem steuern also der Vergleich
hängt so ein bisschen der Staatsbürger
hat Unternehmer sein er muss
Staatsaufgaben wahrnehmen die außerhalb
der unternehmerischen Tätigkeit sehen
also nur eine reine soziale Flankierung
das muss er machen du musst
zielgerichtet sein ich glaube das
Problem dann dürfte auch nicht die
Deutsche Bahn z.B staatlich sein da
müsste man vielleicht auch flughafenbaut
haben also
staatlicher ist in der Stadt sind nur
Eigentümer die Bahn ist ja selbst
privatisiert und wird nach privaten
Regeln geführt sie ist ja nur im
Staatsbesitz also nur das Besitztum
macht sich natürlich zum
Staatsunternehmen das ist dann ja aber
da müssen wir jetzt schon mal ganz
ehrlich bleiben also nicht wie ein
privates Unternehmen ich würde jetzt
nicht so viele Leute sagen jetzt in der
Krise und wurde ja auch nicht geführt
wie eine Behörde also man muss
Unternehmer sein sagen Sie der kriegt
also Steuergeld und soll nur Flanken
machen er muss nicht gucken wie
Haushalten
und Unternehmertum noch mal das Staat
soll ich als Wettbewerber auftreten
Gottes Willen das soll eigentlich tun er
soll nicht produzieren er soll nicht
verteilen aber er muss regeln das muss
ja machen und er muss vor allem den
begrenzen und er muss zielgerichtet die
die Gruppen ansprechen aber er soll
nicht als Unternehmen als Konkurrent
auftreten das tut die Bahn nicht dass du
die Lufthansa nicht dass du in viele
andere auch nicht schlecht wäre etwas
Konkurrenz ganz förderlich wenn man sich
manche Betriebe anguckt als Unternehmer
auftreten das ist dann ist eine ganz
teure Veranstaltung und diese Leute
könnten beispielsweise keine kaum
vorstellen aber ich gebe einfach
weiterhin die die Frage was sind denn
die Ursachen wir haben es gerade schon
bei Herr Bruder probiert zu klären mit
Herr Stahl darüber debattiert das Geld
ist ja da also wenn Politiker hier in
der Runde sitzen sagen sie meiner ja
Geld haben wir eigentlich wir brauchen
nicht mehr Steuereinnahmen wo liegt also
das Problem ich meine das frage ich mich
auch ich bin Schriftsteller und ich bin
eigentlich auf der anderen Seite
sozusagen also als Freiberufler ich
meine in Deutschland redet man nicht so
viel über Gehälter ich bin in
Deutschland nicht sozialisiert also ich
sag mal da irgendwas dazu es war als
freiberuflicher wenn ich ein Artikel
schreibe für eine angesehene Zeitung in
Deutschland und das ist eine Reportage
also ich muss irgendwo Reisen ins
Ausland ich muss da recherchieren dann
komme ich zurück schreibe ich die ganze
Interviews auf und dann schreibe ich den
Text das ist drei drei Wochen Arbeit
sagen wir mal alles insgesamt und das
sind zwei Seiten dann in einer Zeitung
und ich kriege dafür Honorar 500 Euro
und wenn ich dann in der Zeitung Frage
gibt es da irgendwie Spesen weiß ich
nicht Reisekosten sagen sie nein das
war's und dann sagen sie okay aber sie
haben doch ein Stipendium ein
literarisches Stipendium was ich von der
Senatsverwaltung für Kultur und Europa
zum Beispiel bekommen hier in Berlin als
ansässiger in Berlin ansässiger
Schriftsteller da können Sie das doch
querfinanzieren
mhm und also das ganze System was ich
damit sagen will ist also für meinen
Beruf jetzt gesprochen für viele
freiberufliche Künstler Kulturmenschen
ist so konstruiert dass die Wirtschaft
nicht genug Geld abgibt um diese
Leistung die von uns quasi angekauft
wird weil Artikel wird von mir angekauft
ja ich mache irgendetwas produzieren
irgendwas wird gekauft aber das Geld was
dabei rumkommt ist in keinem Verhältnis
zu dem ich mal 500 € kann ich ja auf
jeden Fall schlecht kommen genau und
aber die Wirtschaft rechnet dann damit
okay der Staat hilft nach oder Berlin
hilft nach ja und dann frage ich mich
auch also wie soll das funktionieren und
gleichzeitig aber wenn ich die Frage an
die Unternehmen also sowie die Medien
jetzt irgendwie die meine Arbeit
einkaufen in die Wände und Frage haben
sie nicht mehr Geld dafür was haben wir
nicht dann dann schreiben sie halt keine
Reportage schreiben Sie Publizistik das
kostet nicht so viel da können Sie sich
zu Hause einsetzen auch eingeladen wegen
einem Artikel von ihnen dass es heute
auch ihre These und die würden wir gerne
hören
genau also wir machen jetzt einen
kleinen Sprung zu den Themen Ukraine und
ja ich frage mich also bevor die These
eigentlich eine Frage und zwar was ist
eigentlich unsere Wunschvorstellung was
hätten wir gerne als Ausgang als das
Ideal was wir uns von unserer Politik
gegenüber den Krieg in der Ukraine
vorstellen und da sind für mich so zwei
Aspekte also ein menschlicher Aspekt und
der und der gopolitische Aspekt und der
menschliche Aspekt ist wenn man sich den
Krieg vorstellt dann ist das kein Krieg
zwischen zwei abstrakten Ukrainern den
Ukrainern und den Russen ja es ist ein
Krieg zwischen Menschen also wo Menschen
aufeinander schießen die sehr viel
gemeinsam miteinander haben die zum Teil
die gleiche Sprache sprechen die
vielleicht sogar verwandt sind
miteinander die ähnliches essen mögen
sage ich jetzt mal so pauschal und
vieles andere diese verbindet ja und
einen Krieg kann man vielleicht wenn man
in über einen Krieg nachdenkt als ein
Territorium kann man vielleicht mit
Waffen ein Territorium wieder frei
schießen aber man kann die Herzen von
Menschen nicht frei schießen und in
diesem in diesem Sinne glaube ich nicht
dass man diesen Konflikt mit Waffen
lösen kann weil man wird mit Waffen
irgendwas lösen aber in diesen Herzen
den Menschen bleibt ohne Verlierer ohne
Gewinner ohne Gerechtigkeit ja und das
ist eine Frage die wir uns glaube ich
uns stellen müssen und dann wenn wir
jetzt zu diesem gopolitischen
zurückkommen also die der zweite Aspekt
um sozusagen dann frage ich mich auch
was ist unsere Zielvorstellung also was
ist um sozusagen unser Horizont wenn wir
jetzt denken okay mit Waffengewalt
wollen wir an die Grenzen zurück von
2014 gut aber wir sind eigentlich diese
Grenzen von 2014 entstanden und das muss
ich jetzt alles nicht erzählen wenn wir
die letzten 100 Jahre zurückblicken der
zweite der Zweite Weltkrieg der Erste
Weltkrieg die Revolution die
Bürgerkriegs ähnlichen Zustände in den
20er Jahren all das und dann die Zeit
der Weltmächte Anführungsstrichen die
dann praktisch über die Köpfe der
Menschen hinweg bestimmen wie die
Grenzen verlaufen das ist zwischen Polen
und so und Ukraine so dass es zwischen
Ukraine und Russland so und so weiter
und so fort und ich frage mich ist das
der Horizont wo wir sagen das wäre
Gerechtigkeit wenn wir diesen Zustand
wiederherstellen ich glaube nicht das
ist nicht der Horizont den wir suchen
sollen weil sonst sind wir ständig
hinkriegen wir im Balkan wir machen uns
einmal ganz konkret damit die Zuschauer
auch folgen kann sie fordern eigentlich
einen Waffenstillstand wenn ich sie
richtig verstehe und dass man darauf
hinarbeiten muss bevor der die
Kapitulation der Ukraine das ist was
anderes ich habe doch ich würde hier
auch eine Frage stellen weil man muss
natürlich fragen wie ist dieser
Waffenstillstand zu erreichen hier würde
ich einmal Herr Freund Fragen konkret
hieße das ja wenn ich der Logik Folge
und bitte unterbringen wenn ich es nicht
tue dass man keine Waffen mehr liefern
sollte an die Ukraine es würde auch für
Amerika gelten würden sie damit gehen
ich glaube alle jeder von uns will Ende
des Krieges jeder von uns will keinen
Morgen und kann sterben mehr ich glaube
das ist ja die Frage ist wo kommen wir
her wir haben völkerrechtliche Verträge
hat Russland halt Souveränität der
Grenzen der Ukraine 1991/92 beschäftigt
das haben wir alles und da gibt es
jemanden im Kreml der marschiert durch
Europa der hat sich erst Teile von
Tschetschenien genommen dann hat sich
Teile von Georgien genommen dann hat er
sich Teile von Ukraine genommen und
schauen Sie der hat innenpolitisch
unglaubliche Schwierigkeiten der Mann
und der wird gefeiert als fast als Held
als die Krim und nach Hause kam als
Teile von von Georgien nach Hause kam so
wie es bezeichnet und dieser Mann
braucht diese diese Erfüllung diese
Befriedigung die die sucht er wie ein
Süchtiger weil er zu Hause nichts
vorweisen kann aber gar nichts er sagt
das ganz offen nämlich
Union nicht überwunden Diktatoren sind
ehrlich
in seinem Kampf Alter Überraschung
gewesen
erreichen und absolut durch Europa sieht
sie mit dem Stift zieht die Grenzen neu
und er hört er nicht auf es ist ein
Irrglauben zu denken wie einiges jetzt
der kriegt also Teile ab wofür
eigentlich kriegt Teile ab des Landes
dann ist er ja nicht zu Ende der macht
ja weiter er macht ja in Syrien hat er
weiter gemacht der hat so eine Mörder
Truppe diese wagnertruppe okay aber ich
meine wir haben sogar noch rum also es
ist ein Irrtum zu glauben man könnte mit
dem peacement hätte man damals im Nazi
Deutschland Hitler stoppen können aber
wir haben wir haben ja keinen Einfluss
darauf und worauf die Einfluss haben ist
unsere Politik und auch unsere Frage
stellen ob ich als Schriftsteller
versuch mich da auch irgendwie ein
bisschen um zu sagen tiefer zu gucken
und nicht zu fragen okay welche Welt
wünsche ich mir eigentlich weil das ist
kein Krisenmanagement und ich das das
Wort fallen sollen sie ja total
interessieren von 1991 ist der
gewährleistet worden und das und das hat
auch super aber dazwischen die in dieser
Grenze ja wollte ich auch oft unterwegs
unterwegs war erleben Leute die wie
gesagt russisch sprechen auf der einen
oder auf der anderen Seite oder bis vor
kurzem haben solche gelebt die leben
Menschen die ihre Verwandten haben auf
der einen und auf der anderen Seite und
dem allen wollen wir irgendwie Rechnung
tragen genau auf Italienisch und
wunderbaren gehören aber da ist die
Europäische Union und hier nicht und wir
müssen uns fragen glaube ich meine
österreichische lange in der
Europäischen Union drin wir haben Teile
in Dänemark die sind auch
deutschsprachig wir haben Teile in
Ostbelgien die sind deutschsprachig
haben und trotzdem ist es nicht
Deutschland ich sag einfach mal ich gehe
mal keinen Krieg dafür
ein bisschen shoppen hol mal ein
bisschen Krieg rüber sie müssen den Mann
einfach mitteilen es ist hier zu Ende
dein Elixier aus dem du in politisch
Kraft ziehst aber dafür aber
nicht teilnehmenden Temperaturen und ich
lasse Leute sterbe ich die größte
Überreichung
nacheinander sonst hat hier keiner mehr
Spaß der Bruder ich bin sehr viel Spaß
das ist schon okay ich finde nur wenn
Sie fragen welche Welt wir uns wünschen
ich kann das ganz klar sagen ich wünsche
mir eine Welt wo Schriftsteller aufhören
über Politik zu fantasieren das war ein
Fortschritt schon und sagen Sie mir ein
Beispiel wo Schriftsteller mit deren
durchaus humanen wunderbaren gleich ein
galitären Gedanken die Welt verändert
haben haben sie was erreicht sie als
Schriftsteller ich meine
kleingeschrieben haben die Leute was
erreicht die sich mit Hitler
angefreundet haben die Stalin zugejubelt
haben die Geschichte des
versagensfreunden aber hier von
anfreunden entgegenkommen
da gibt es vieles eines ich glaube wir
müssen uns auch ein bisschen in den
Debatten davon lösen dass wir mit
Feststellungen argumentieren ja dass wir
sagen sie machen eine Feststellung und
dann ist die Welt so
können Sie das
belegene Erfahrungen mit historisches
erfahren ja bitte die sind evident
welche historischen Erfahrungen sind da
kommen 1988 eine ganze Politik den Nazis
gegenüber verstehen sie die Konferenz
von Evian was darum ging die deutschen
Juden zu retten als die Konferenz
Erfolges auseinander ging wo ist der
Hitler kann machen was er will wenn man
dem Bösen nicht von Anfang an Panorama
glaube ich gesagt die nötigen
Grausamkeiten müssen am Anfang brauchen
unsere Referenz ist horizonter danke
dass die Talent auf jeden Fall das wäre
nämlich gewesen genau das ist nämlich
der Punkt unsere referenzhose und das
1815 und der Wiener Kongress und eine
Reaktion eines reaktionärer Politik
gegenüber der französischen Revolution
und dem alles was danach war und das ist
nämlich glaube ich das Problem weil wir
nämlich seitdem innerhalb von Grenzen
reden die nicht gerecht ist haben für
die Menschen sehen können
immer vielleicht
abschaffen aber vielleicht ein bisschen
locker lassen
oder wenn man nach den Grenzen geht dann
müsste man sagen ist die Ukraine nicht
mit drinnen in unserem Bündnis wenn man
Grenzen nimmt
Datum
eingelassen was in Deutschland kein
guten Ruf hat die leisten Widerstand
wenn wir über Grenzen reden ist doch
keiner nicht mit drin es gab Verträge es
gab Abkommen es gab Regelungen unter
anderem hat die Ukraine
leichtsinnigerweise wäre Atomwaffen
verzichtet statt sich so viele zu
benehmen wie Nordkorea es macht mit
Atomwaffen wäre wahrscheinlich dieser
russische Einfall nicht passiert aber
diese Verträge konservieren ja praktisch
das was wir seit 200 Jahren in Europa
haben wollen die Europa nur Europa neu
ziehen ich sage nicht wieder haben was
sagen sie dazu ich will nicht ich sage
nicht was ich will in Europa machen ich
möchte eine Debatte starten darüber die
einfach sich im Klaren ist dass wir hier
mit Umständen zu tun haben mit vertagten
Entscheidungen vertagt und Debatten mit
Ergebnissen von machtpolitischen
Entscheidungen
entscheidet ja wer Experte ist bei dem
Thema grundsätzlich
ich will vielleicht
ich höre viele Dinge ich habe in der
Geschichte auch aufgepasst und wenn wir
hier schon darüber reden was damals und
was heute sich ähnelt wenn wir von
Diktatoren sprechen
möchte ich alle hier im Raum und da
draußen an eines erinnern an etwas ganz
Wichtiges
wenn wir ihn schon mit Hitler
vergleichen ja
dieser Mann
schießt nicht mit Gewehren dieser Mann
besitzt
6.600
Atomwaffen
6600 Atomwaffen und wenn dieser Mann
seine Macht verliert weist er dass sein
Leben vorbei ist also bitte ich alle
dieses Spielchen auf einem Schachbrett
was wir hier spielen genau zu überdenken
ich weiß nicht auf wen von ihnen schon
geschossen wurde auf mich ist geschossen
worden
nee mit Atomwaffen nicht der Wanne Waffe
schon ausreichend aber schießen tut man
mehr Atomwaffen nicht man drückt nur auf
den Knopf und diese Macht hat dieser
Mann und ich bitte das ist den
Philosophie der Kapitulation
kapitulieren soll hier keiner ich will
nur daran erinnern dass wir 6600 Waffen
da auf der anderen Seite haben wir jetzt
verstanden
so viel und wir haben schon so Angst
völlig irrelevant sie können mit einer
Atomwaffe halb Europa auslösen das wird
nicht Europa treffen wenn dann sich ein
Ziel aussucht dann wird das Ziel
ich habe nur einen direkten Drahtzug
Gerhard Schröder das ist schon schlimm
genug
sie Fantasien etwas herbei ich habe
etwas vor etwas Angst was real ist aber
mit ihrer Angst müssen sie alleine
fertig werden ich habe andere Ängste ich
habe die Angst es wird keine Beute der
Kekse mehr geben das wäre für mich das
Schlimmste na ja es ist entschuldige das
ist vollkommen albern seien sie mir
nicht böse ich verehre sie ja aber das
ist völliger Unsinn mit dieser
Argumentation kann jeder Diktator alles
unternehmen kann alles vernichten
sind sie besorgt um Atomwaffen ja
natürlich
aber dann heißt also
wir müssen dann überhaupt nicht warten
bis Putin einen Schritt weiter geht wir
können gleich sagen was 6000 Euro
Atomwaffen wir geben die gleich Estland
Lettland Dieter und Polen Tschechien
Slowakei Ungarn Rumänien Bulgarien die
Moldau ja und vielleicht noch ein Stück
von Griechenland weil es auch mal eine
russische Migration gegeben hat ich
wollte auf einen Punkt zurückkommen ich
wiederhole mich ungern aber diesmal muss
ich machen ich habe das schon mal gesagt
putin ist Hitler und noch Holocaust und
das ist nicht unangemessen sagen Sie
jetzt nicht dass das einmalig war das
war einmalig aber abgesehen davon dass
er keine Massenvernichtung mit
industriellen Mitten betreibt macht er
die grau die gleiche Taktik und
Strategie verbrannte Erde Massenmord
Nötigung Entführung die reine Gewalt und
wenn er somit ist wie er wie sie ihn
beschreiben was hält ihn davon ab das in
den letzten Schritt zu machen genau wie
Hitler den totalen
will warum wissen sie der Mann hat so
viele Immobilien im Westen warum sollte
sich umbringen der kann auf seine Jagd
gehen die gerade den kann vor allem das
ist wenn die Gerüchte stimmen dass er
krank ist
spekulationsniveau gerade
wenn er krank
das ist ganz einfach
wenn ich der erste Diktator dabei
also ich finde es schön dass wir alles
so schön blumig malen ich hoffe dass es
so ist und dass wir dass es nie dazu
kommt denn wenn es dazu kommt kann ich
was sagen haben sie sie können ihm geben
was sie wollen gar nichts geht
auf dieser Welt herrscht und nicht nur
nicht eine Ukraine sondern sonst überall
dann fahren wir doch bei jemand an
furchtbar stattfinden genau
Millionen von Menschen verreckt sind
aber seit weit weg das ist das
entscheidende warum wir darüber
wahrscheinlich nicht so reden gar nicht
mit einem Druck auf einer Taste sind sie
heute mit jedem nicht interessiert und
sagt
nichts interessiert und Insel also hat
die krimisch interessiert letzter
Konsequenzen nur weil es jetzt auf
breiter Front Geschehen Vertrag wurde
nach der Annexion der Krimi glaublich
nein das war die Sanktion Helmut Schmidt
hat sogar angefangen seit 80 Jahren des
Mann in meine Röhren Deal zu
unterschreiben da gehen die ganze Elend
ja los mit der russischen Gas
Abhängigkeit das hat ja dann fortgesetzt
also das ist ja kein Prozess der letzte
Bundesregierung eigentlich
gegenüber solchen Leuten die Putin
auftreten wenn er entschlossen ist zum
Untergang dann wird er auch dann dieses
diesen Entschluss durchsetzen wenn wir
ihn vorher wissen sie Churchill hat
gesagt
it isment ist eine Pizza ist jemand dein
Krokodil füttert in der Hoffnung es
werde das letzten Essen und genau das
ist jetzt unsere Situation
und noch mal zu den Grenzen natürlich
sind alle Grenzen willkürlich in Europa
sind sie weitgehend auf also wir haben
viele Verfassung wir haben ja den Rücken
Status des Verfassungsstaates wenn man
Beispiel also durch Frankreich natürlich
sehr homogen und Staatsgebilde so von
der Form her dann gibt es natürlich die
Schweiz zum Beispiel ist ein klassischer
Verfassungsstaat da gibt es also Tessin
da gibt's die Franzose und bis heute ist
das ja sind die auch politisch da sehr
sehr gespalten wir haben es eine Ukraine
da haben sie vollkommen Recht da haben
wir natürlich Minderheiten und so weiter
und so fort viele Grenzen es ist ein
Land zu überfallen starten und keine
organische einmal unterbrechen ich
glaube da sind vereinig am Tisch das
niemand sagt dass der Angriffskrieg in
irgendeiner Form legitimiert ist egal
auf dieser Welt ist nicht legitim egal
welcher nicht nur hier egal
jeder für Sie da
[Musik]
also da kann ich ja ein lauter kochen
und ich ernst nehmen als sogenannten
Experten
herzlich willkommen meine Damen und
Herren bei viertel nach fünf Köpfe fünf
Meinungen von jeder von uns hat ein
Thema mitgebracht dass sie bewegt ärgert
freut oder schockiert
so nicht Privatjet Uschi Wetten
aber niemand von den politischen
Parteien traut sich zu sagen ja das
wollen wir einfach nur Freiheit wir sind
grünroten stehen da und führen
hochtrabende Debatten über die Rettung
des Weltklimas und um die Füße rum wo
wollen die Ratten das Thema ist viel zu
wichtig uns nur der AFD zu überlassen
lass den Leuten noch mal den Spaß wir
sehen da etwas was eigentlich fatal ist
in der Politik bei den Journalisten
deren Job ist es doch gerade abweichende
Meinungen zu finden und sie sollen den
doch auch richtig doof finden
zu Manko vielleicht einmal kurz an das
Auto hinterlassen auch das sind
irgendwelche anorakträger aus Buxtehude
die das Gucken ich habe meinen Beifall
meine lache immer bekommen wer kümmert
sich darum niemand das ist falsch ja man
muss da ganz klar jetzt mal auch darüber
sprechen dass es einfach nicht fair ist
und nicht richtig Aufgabe von
Journalismus einfach die die
Verlautbarung der Politik zu
hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und machen direkt weiter
mit der These von Herrn
sind dran bezüglich welcher Frage
mitgebracht haben für eine These das ist
doch jeder von uns ein Thema mitgebracht
genau
also meine These ist natürlich dass wir
Frieden und Freiheit verteidigen müssen
zurzeit und das natürlich einige
Beschwernisse geben wird noch einige
soziale Härten geben wird wir haben
ausführlich darüber gesprochen aber das
sind Dinge die kurzfristig ins weh tun
aber mittleren langfristig werden uns
Frieden Freiheit Wohlstand bringen und
auch und auch
allgemeine allgemeines Glückseligkeit
wenn ich mal so sagen darf das heißt
gibt auch Amerika hat dort als ein
Beitrag geleistet und das ist mein
zentrale These Amerika unterstützt hier
ist eine der größten der Schütze wenn
ich der großen Schütze der Ukraine
zurzeit und vertritt dort eben und
Frieden und Freiheit und eben auch
Gesetzmäßigkeiten und das eben niemand
durch Europa gehen kann kann die Grenzen
neu und sagen ich bin jetzt hier und
annektiere Gebiete völkerrechtswidrig
sondern dass wir eben dafür einstehen
und dass wir eben verteidigen wie
Deutschland verteidigt worden ist von
den Amerikanern eben nach dem Zweiten
Weltkrieg Herr Freund ich habe hier
direkt eine Frage sie haben gerade
gesagt es wird uns wehtun sprechen Sie
davon Deutschland oder von Amerika und
welche Opfer hat bislang Amerika
gebracht im Ukraine Krieg also einige
Opfer gebracht auch die Gaspreise und
die Ölpreise sind genauso gestiegen in
USA wie profitiert nein nein die
Ölindustrie nein
Amerika kann ich Ihnen sagen die
Ölindustrie macht Amerika ungefähr 6%
des Sozialproduktes aus also das ist
unbedeutend was viel mehr wehtut ist wir
Amerika rutscht jetzt auch in der
Rezession rein Amerika zahlt genauso die
gleichen hohen Energiekosten und Amerika
hat sogar ein doch
nein Amerika profitiert laut Energie und
Gasbetrieb das ist nicht dass sie
dieselbe Kosten haben wie Deutschland
ganz langsam Amerika rutschen Rezession
rein die Gaspreise in Amerika
unglaublich gestiegen haben es ebenfalls
verdreifacht die Ölpreise handelt auch
gestiegen USA und Amerika ist übrigens
energieintensiver als Deutschland auch
das stimmt kann ich Ihnen sagen wir
sehen in Deutschland weniger prozentual
betrachtet vom Sozialprodukt
energieintensiv als die USA also Amerika
wird genauso getroffen von den
Wirtschaftssanktionen Deutschland
gerade eben hochschießen und die Fett
hat sogar früher sprechen über den
Ukraine kriegt die Wirtschaftssanktionen
treffen Amerika genauso wie Deutschland
die
wirtschaftsaktionen müssen aufpassen
höhere Energiepreise trifft die
amerikanische Volkswirtschaft
tendenziell stärker als die deutsche
Volkswirtschaft aber wer das dann nicht
so wenn Sie das so sagen dass wir
vielleicht auch gerade daraus einen
Impuls nehmen diese Politik die wir
führen zu überdenken weil sie nämlich
uns schadet wie sie auch sagen Amerika
ist nicht aber wenn Sie das so sagen es
schadet auf jeden Fall der Ukraine und
schadet auch den Menschen die in
Russland haben rede nicht von der
Politik sondern von den Menschen
kurzfristig ganz genau
Krieg ein Jahr ist doch gar nichts
einmal da drin schaut mal entschuldigen
vor Ort sagen das ist gar nicht sie
sprechen ja absolut ja lang wir müssen
einem Land der sechs Jahre kriegt
durchgemacht haben
schauen Sie sich doch mal an Amerika hat
sich ein ist ein Kriegseintritt im
Zweiten Weltkrieg gehabt im Dezember 41
und hat dann dreieinhalb Jahre lang
gekämpften hohen blutsoll geleistet aber
möchten Sie das möchten Sie nein ja
genau aber was meinen die Alternative
Szenario wie wir machen mit wir machen
es mit na das wir haben auf Putin kein
Einfluss aber wir haben darauf
durchmachen
nächste Woche stehen
Amerika es ist noch so aber davon mal
abgesehen wissen Sie dieses Land hier in
dem wir glücklichen zufrieden leben hat
sich lange in Sicherheit gewinnt weil
die Amerikaner ihre schützende Hand über
Deutschland gehalten haben auf die Weise
konnten Milliarden gespart und in
Sozialprojekte geleitet werden und jetzt
sind wir gebeten einen gewissen Anteil
dieser letzten zu übernehmen und das ist
schon zu viel aber er wurde und ich kann
doch nicht mehr so geführt werden wie
damals also da hat er keine Stadion
angefangen
man kann die Krieger nicht vergleichen
wir können ja nicht 1941 bis heute
vergleichen man kann die Bedrohung durch
einen Diktator durch ein Tyrann durch
einen Massenmörder durch ein seelenloses
menschliches Wesen man kann die
vergleichen
eingesetzt ja dann setze ich nicht mehr
jung genug ja genau also wäre es doch
trotzdem immer wieder müssen wir noch
alle Möglichkeiten hätten eher die
Nazifizierung Europas in Kauf genommen
Kapitel der Atome gehabt hätte und kein
Risiken
wie viele Millionen Deutsche ich werde
auf die Straße gegangen ja ja weil ich
hätte nicht einfach zu mir hätten sie
wahrscheinlich den Lauf der Geschichte
verändert nicht aber ich habe zumindest
versucht ausgeschlossen
und Russland ja und da ist schon meine
Frage Bruder wie kann es denn jetzt
überhaupt ausgehen das weiß ich nicht
das weiß niemand es ist sozusagen
das ist leider so der Zweite Weltkrieg
ist so ausgegangen wer ausgegangen ist
aufgrund ihrer Zufälle zum Beispiel dass
ich Churchill durchgesetzt hat gegen die
Pro deutschen pro nazik-kräfte in
England in England sie hatte auch nicht
so kommen müssen natürlich ist ein
Risiko es ist ein Risiko für alle nur zu
sagen wir werden uns gar nicht weil
unsere gegenwärt in Aggressor nur noch
stärker im provoziert provoziert demütig
da stehen sie das geredet dass die NATO
sich auf die auf Russland zu bewegt hat
ich meine russland hat den ganzen Gürtel
um sich gehabt von Trabanten und Sabine
aber die Debatte welcher Krieg ist
wichtiger als der andere das muss man ja
dann schon die Frage des Menschenrechts
universell das heißt es gibt ja nicht
nur Putin den Diktator in der Welt nein
es gibt noch diesen Mann dein Nordkorea
das ist Dickerchen ja aber wissen Sie
irgendwo muss man anfangen und am besten
man fängt von der Haustür an deswegen
finde ich Putin für gefährliche und
bedrohlicher als diesen
Frieden gemacht
bitte ist auch eine Veto macht nur in
Sicherheitsrat und mit Nordkorea nicht
ganz zu vergleichen und gucken sie an
was für Massaker die angestellt haben
wir Putin Assad geholfen hat das Land
kaputt zu machen wie viele Millionen
Flüchtlinge da sind wie viele Tote ist
da gegeben hat das hat uns auch lange
nicht interessant
aber wir haben dieses Feindbild Amerika
und wenn sie jetzt sagen Amerika
profitiert davon ich kenne das alles ich
bin mit der These aufgewachsen dass die
Amerikaner nur deswegen in Amerika
weniger und ein Wirtschaftsamt
ohne zu kommentieren was der Bruder oder
ich sagen das wäre ganz freundlicher
Freund vielen Dank okay danke schön aber
lass sie sagen ja ich möchte aber hier
einmal das noch zu ihnen sagen es ist ja
schon so dass gerade Deutschland mehr
leidet also man muss ja sagen wenn wir
sagen Opfer bringen Deutschland leidet
mehr als andere Länder unter den
Wirtschaft Sanktionen als andere
europäische Länder wir leiden mehr als
beispielsweise Amerika unter den
Sanktionen und dann fordert von uns
immer mehr wie viel kann Deutschland
denn machen bis Deutschland selbst
Bankrott gibt es Mitleid mit den tiefen
Leiden der deutschen die vielleicht
schon dreimal nur zweimal im Jahr einen
Urlaub fahren können das ist weitaus
mehr als das ja Bruder bitte ich ich
verbiete mir diese Respektlosigkeit
gegenüber den Menschen
sprechen dann können sie ja trotzdem
aber ich will meine Stimme da jemand
sagen dafür stehe ich nicht ein dass sie
sowas somit vergleichen sie werden auf
dem Dritten Reich auf die Straße
gegangen ich wäre auf jeden Fall ich
gehe ich auch jetzt auf die und erhebe
meine Stimme für heute im Dritten Reich
bitte nee ich vergleiche Ungerechtigkeit
mit Ungerechtigkeiten und die sind damit
schlecht gewesen und falsch und sind
heute schlecht und falsch und wenn
Menschen nicht einstellen ihre Stimme
nicht erheben dann passiert schlimmer
und der ja eben unsere Stimme ich weiß
nicht wie weit sie meine Arbeit kennen
egal liebe meine Stimme und er hat
stellt dafür ein und ich habe nur mal
hunderte tausende von E-Mails bekommen
von Menschen und wenn die ihre Worte
erzählen dann finden die nicht richtig
oder erhebe ich meine Stimme und sagen
Sie einfach so nicht tut mir furchtbar
leid dass sie auf ihre Klientel keine
Rücksicht das sind ein paar Millionen
vergleichen Sie bitte die Menschen nicht
die sich einsetzen nee habe ich sie
kommen immer von heute übrigens immer
wieder die Hitler bei dem Thema wir
haben nämlich auch noch die These heute
von Herrn Bruder und die wollen wir ihn
auch gar nicht vorenthalten und
vielleicht herrscht bei dem Thema etwas
mehr Einigkeit am Tisch jetzt kommt das
Happy End hoffentlich hat Zustand dafür
sind die zuständig fürs Handy
Aufstehen mich tief verbeugen und zwar
von den Frauen im Iran
unglaublichen Kampf ausfechten die
wirklich etwas riskieren der auf die
Straße gehen und nicht nur auf die
Straße gehen die erleben ihre Gesundheit
ihrer Familien und ihre ganze Existenz
riskieren nach 40 Jahren Monat Diktatur
gibt es im Iran offenbar immer noch die
Rest einer bürgerlichen Gesellschaft die
den Frieden und die Freiheit schätzt und
das sind unsere Verbündeten die wir bis
jetzt im Stich gelassen haben weil uns
die wirtschaftlichen Beziehungen mit
diesen Mullah terror-system wichtiger
waren diese Frauen sind großartig und
wenn ich wenn ich mir überlege wenn ich
am meisten bewundere dann sind es an der
erster Stelle die Frauen in Meran und
zweiten Stelle die Ukraine die sich
verteidigen und die nicht kapitulieren
wollen auch nicht vor einem atomaren
Drohung aber zurück zu den Frauen das
ist eine absolut unerwartete und von
allen unseren Experten nicht
vorhergesehene Geschichte das ist dieses
widerstandspotenzial dort gibt und wie
helfen wir diese Leute deshalb bei
kleinen Demos gegeben aber im Prinzip
ist Schweigen im Walde nicht wahr unsere
Feministinnen reden über die genderstern
über Quoten über die transophobie in
diesem Land es gibt keine große
Demonstration niemand geht hier durch
die Straßen wirst du Zeit das Casa
Konflikt zwar und ruft zum Beispiel Mula
Frauenmörder oder Müller Kindermörder
verstehen sie wir lassen die Leute im
Stich das ist das ist das was wir am
besten können nämlich Leute im Stich
lassen den westmeckt aber schon toll im
Stich gelassen und Tschechien im Stich
gelassen und ich vergleiche sehr wohl
Geschichte weil geschichte wiederholt
sich nicht aber sie macht spiralische
Bewegungen und kommt oft ohne es zu
wollen zum selben Ziel also nochmal
an wenn ich nicht verheiratet wäre würde
ich jetzt nach Iran fahren wenn wir dort
eine Frau suchen ich glaube es stimmen
alle am Tisch zu dass man
selbstverständlich nur tiefe Verehrung
davor haben kann es gibt ja Aktionen wie
beispielsweise in Frankreich da
schneiden sich Schauspielerinnen ein
Stück der Haare ab die Haare sind nicht
es ist immer so ein Stück was halten Sie
denn von Aktionen wie dieser ich weiß
worauf sich hinaus wurden es ist eine
symbol-handlung sie setzt wenig um sie
bewirkt wenig aber sie macht vielleicht
den Leuten im Iran Mut und sind
mobilisiert andere ich weiß es ist eine
minimalistische Handlung es bringt nicht
viel aber es bringt immer noch mehr als
einfach zu Hause zu sitzen und sich zu
grämen ich will dazu einen guten
Beispiel bringen wir haben den die
Diskussion Iran und diese Atom über die
atomanreicherung Atomwaffen Diskussion
und man wäre sogar am besten bereit zu
sagen man würde wieder Iran in die
Welthandelsorganisation aufnehmen wieder
am wirtschaftlichen Leben
internationalen handelsströmung
teilhaben lassen wenn man denn dort mit
den Abkommen trifft man vergisst dort
vollkommen ah diese innenpolitischen
Schwierigkeiten mit denen sie wieder und
noch viel mehr das um den Iran herum
konventionelle finden Kriege finanziert
werden also wir reden gar nicht darüber
dass die im Irak dort Thesen im Libanon
im Jemen in allen an selbst in Saudi
Arabien sorgen sie für Unruhe in jedem
angrenzenden Land unterstützte Iran
konventionelle Krieger
wir sind bereit unterwegs ist diese
wieder als deutsche Bundesregierung
wieder in die Welt Staatengemeinschaften
punktu Welthandel aufzunehmen nur wenn
er etwas unterlässt das Atom das Uran
anreichert also alles andere übersehen
wir und machen wir und das kann er tun
finde ich entsetzlich bleiben wir einmal
bei den Frauen im Iran wir wollen ja auf
Herr Bruder eingehen wie sie stehen Sie
dazu also ich kann total gut
nachempfinden was sie sagen Herr Bruder
dass nämlich ja eine Perspektive und ein
also ein Anerkennen praktisch für diese
Leute letztlich auch bedeutende
Perspektive also Symbol Handlungen sind
gut aber ich kann mich erinnern ich war
ja viel in der arabischen Welt unterwegs
und ich meine spreche auch selber
arabisch und wenn ich mich daran in der
sogenannte arabische Frühling was da in
den Ländern passiert ist viele Leute
sind auf die Straßen gegangen haben
demonstriert haben gesagt wir wollen uns
um sozusagen dem Westen annähern wir
wollen diese Diktatoren loswerden und
was ist passiert dann sagten sie mir
nach einem Jahr oder zwei Jahren und ihr
redet damit sie sie anstatt mit den
Leuten zu reden die diese Revolution
machen und mit denen zu überlegen wir
wir den Staat anders ihm gestalten
können und wie wir letztlich also ich
bin ein großer Freund von dieser Idee
dass das mit der mediterrane Raum
praktisch also ein Teil von Europa sein
musste in irgendeiner Form die kenne ich
nicht und die müssen wir diskutieren im
Stich lassen ich weiß es jetzt noch
nicht es ist vielleicht zu früh zu sagen
aber ich habe Angst dass ich dieses
Szenario um sozusagen wiederholt dass
die Leute die dann demonstrieren und da
irgendwie erst mal riskieren auch
mitunter ihr Leben und dann nach ein
paar Monaten kann man sagen okay wir
haben das ins Banken gebracht vielleicht
ist da was passiert wir wissen Ägypten
passiert ist oder in Tunesien oder auch
andere oder in Syrien ich meine das hat
ja auch damals so angefangen und was ist
jetzt was ist jetzt in Syrien nach
dieser Zeit ja und ich meine haben wir
nicht diese Leute im Stich gelassen oder
haben wir auch nicht die
Demonstrierenden Ägypter im Stich
gelassen ja wir haben sie zumindest
nicht ermuntert auf die Straße zu gehen
es war ein genuiner Vorgang aus der
Gesellschaft aber sie wollten eine
Perspektive
Bewunderung für die Leute wissen Sie
diese Perspektive
korrupten Gesellschaften und Systeme
nicht mit pandemonstrationen ändern wenn
sie keine Eliten haben wenn sie keine
gebildeten Leute haben wenn ihr ganzes
politisch sie sagen das ist in Ägypten
keine Eliten und keine gebildeten Leute
gibt
einige Leben bereits in Europa weil sie
dort nicht ausgehalten haben aber es
gibt auch
andere sind nicht im Stande die
Gesellschaft zu verändern und das hat
offen was zu tun mit der Geschichte
dieser Gesellschaften mit der religiösen
Orientierung mit dem Mangel an
Bürgerrechten wir können von Europa aus
nicht Gesellschaften zu ihrem Glück
steuern und ich finde wir haben schon
genug Steuern nicht aber eine
Perspektive anbieten für diese Menschen
die eben dieses System ändern wollen die
haben wir ja wir haben überall
Goethe-Institute
reinholen und Fragen finden Sie denn das
Druck für die Frauen im Iran ja
vielleicht sagen wir auch einfach mal
demonstriert wird in unserem Land
natürlich nur eine symbolische Handlung
aber immerhin etwas also wichtig ist
dass man auf Unterdrückung aufmerksam
macht so und ist ja genau das was jetzt
auch wenn sich nur ein Stück der Haare
abschneiden aber es geht ja darum dass
man dass man eine Symbolwirkung macht
und damit auf das Problem aufmerksam
macht denn viele bekommen das ja gar
nicht mit ja manche Medien berichten
darüber auch gar nicht und das ist schon
total traurig
mit der eisbucket Challenge und sagen
wichtiger machen als das sind nämlich
über den Mainstream lassen Sie sie
wissen ich kenne den kämpfe für
Kinderschutz und das sage ich ja immer
wieder wir gehen für alles auf die
Straße blacklab matter gegen Homophobie
für LGB Kitty und all das und doch und
auch viele Männer für Kinderschutz und
dann haben wir nämlich in Deutschland
das gleiche geht kein Schwein auf die
Straße obwohl jeden Tag Kinder zu zu 100
Millionen aber das ist genau das man
muss es anstoßen das ist genau das wie
ich dieses Thema und andere für
Kinderschutz machen ist es wichtig dass
diese Frauen machen der Unterschied ich
riskiere hier in meinem Land dafür zum
Glück noch nicht mein Leben diese Frauen
und da hat er natürlich Recht das
absolute respekt das wird dass sie das
da machen wenn sie und das was sie sich
da was sie da machen und was sie die
Gefahren der sich ausgeben die will man
sich ja nicht vorstellen aber ob das
ausreicht wenn sich ein paar Stars ein
paar Herrchen und ihre likes vor allen
Dingen generieren wollen weil sie wieder
mal eine Mainstream generieren glaube
ich nicht dass das ausreicht da muss
viel mehr passieren also doch eher als
bucket Challenge nee garantiert nicht
ich glaube schon aber vielleicht sollten
sie noch ein bisschen mehr machen als
ich nur die Haare abschneiden vielleicht
sollten Sie einfach wirklich auf die
Straße gehen oder vor allen Dingen ihren
Einfluss ihre Reichweiten nutzen
vielleicht auch ein bisschen Geld
generieren für diese Menschen das tun
sie nämlich nicht wenn Haare abschneiden
super war und ich habe wieder ein paar
likes generiert ja aber das ist bei
allen Themen die Mainstream sind sie
benutzen Sie sie werden benutzt
eigentlich mehr für die eigene Wirkung
als für die Sache an sich und das ist
das Traurige daran ja mach mal Kniefall
jetzt dafür mach meine Armbinde und das
Warten dann lassen sie wieder im Stich
Verwendung und gehen mit tiefen Respekt
vor den Frauen im Iran raus aus der
Sendung und wir sehen uns nächste Woche
wieder wenn Sie mögen tschüss schönen
Abend noch
[Musik]